from the opening credits men in black
International feels every bit like the
rest of the franchise just with better
CGI and some fresh faces it also makes
clever nods to its past as well as other
familiar movies here are a few small
details you may have missed it's become
difficult to separate Chris Hemsworth
from the Thunder God Thor the is
Guardian Avenger of Marvel superhero
movies with Hemsworth starring is the
hammer swingin hero in three solo films
and all for Avengers installments it's
safe to say there are plenty of movie
goers who might not know who Hemsworth
was if it weren't for his MCU flicks it
can be a problem when an actor so
closely associated with one roll stars
and something different but rather than
ignore the proverbial elephant in the
room
men in black international has some
clever fun with it towards the end of
the film
agents H&M and their sidekick Pawnee
infiltrate the fortress of an alien arms
dealer agent age gets into a fight with
the dealers super-strong bodyguard and
he's clearly outmatched
at one point H spots a small hammer and
grabs it but H isn't nearly as skilled
and Hammer based combat as Thor exactly
tales of time
agent H's brief hammer related delusion
of grandeur isn't the only nod to the
MCU in a battle against twin alien
villains agent H bravely steps forward
and warns the villains that they're
facing the men in black then he corrects
himself the men and women in black yeah
perfectly good the moment works even
without the reference but it's
nonetheless a nod to asine Hemsworth and
Tessa Thompson cher in 2017 s thor
ragnarok while thor is still a slave and
is about to be sent into the arena to
fight thor sees a tattoo on Thompson's
yet-to-be-named character's armed that
marks her as one of the Valkyrie an
elite force of his guardian warrior
women desperately trying to get in her
good graces so she'll help him escape
Thor stumbles over his words before
flashing Thompson a similar smile and a
thumbs up I think it's great but there
is a an elite force of women warriors
about time in 1997's men in black
shortly after agent J is accepted into
the MIB agent K brings the new recruit
to the armory K chooses an impressive
series for D atomizer for himself while
handing J a teeny tiny thing that looks
like it might be a keychain or a fancy
kitchen gadget he calls it the noisy
cricket and J is unimpressed
of course J later learns the noisy
cricket is one of many things in men and
black that should not be judged by its
outer appearance
apparently the noisy cricket is still in
use and MIB isn't any better about
educating new agents about it shortly
after agent M is accepted as a
probationary agent we get a montage
similar to the one we see in 1997's men
in black when agent J is inducted M is
given a new wardrobe sunglasses to
protect her from the amnesia inducing
neuralyzer x' and then it's time to
choose her weapon agent M lifts the
noisy cricket daintily out of its case
and looking at the camera lets us know
there's no way she'll be trusting this
dinky little thing with her safety
unfortunately there's no agent K around
to let her know just how much stuff that
little thing can blow up if you're
worried men in black international is
yet another Hollywood reboots some small
details let you know that isn't the case
there's agent oh of course who first
appeared in men in black 3 but there are
also some artistic details in the office
of agent hi t the head of the agency's
London branch men in black International
opens on agents H and hi T a few years
earlier teaming up to fight aliens known
as the hive the villains are coming to
earth via of portal and Paris's Eiffel
Tower the prologue cuts away before we
see how that scenario ends but we later
hear different agents speaking of it
with great reverence we also see a
painting meant to represent this victory
in agent hi T's office but this Paris
battle isn't the only immortalized
moment blink and you'll miss it but not
far from the Paris painting is one of
the more familiar J&K in the final
battle of 1997 s men in black as they
battled the giant bug at the observation
towers of the New York World's Fair so
while we never learned what happened to
J and K the painting lets us know
International is a continuation of the
series rather than a do-over
men in black International does a good
job of paying tribute to the earlier
films without getting too bogged down in
the past perfect examples include a pair
of cameos from popular aliens we've seen
before
when Molly first Bluffs her way into the
MIB headquarters the old man watching
the elevator is accompanied by a pug in
a dog bed at his feet once molly slips
into the elevator the Pug says talk
about amateur hour and we instantly
recognize the voice of Tim Blaney the
actor who did the voice of Frank the pug
in the first two men
black films I know later after she's
discovered and accepted into the agency
agent M walks past a group of short and
Tenet wisecracking aliens instantly
recognizable as the same guys that
shocked agent J when he saw them hanging
out in the MIB break room in the first
film when we meet agent H he's involved
in an undercover op posing as a gambler
for some kind of alien card game where
players have to reach into a cage
holding a poisonous three-headed snake
in order to get their cards the game is
overseen by an alien crook named Luca
Brasi a pretty blatant reference to
1972's classic mafia epic The Godfather
in The Godfather Luca Brasi is strangled
to death while trying to infiltrate a
rival gang the character was played by
Leni Montana a former professional
wrestler as well as a real-life mob
enforcer the Corleone's learn of
brassey's murder when a package is
delivered including fish wrapped in
grassi's vest leading to one of the
film's most famous lines if you caught
the reference in men in black
international you probably guessed the
fate of the alien Luca Brasi a mission
accomplished he sleeps with the fishes
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]